[Music]
many passages in the Quran directly and
indirectly exhort Muslims to commit acts
of violence the Quran says and slay them
wherever you find them and expel them
from where they expelled you persecution
is more Grievous than slaughter but
fight them not by the holy MO until they
should fight you there and then if they
fight you slay them such is the
recompense of unbelievers but if they
give over surely Allah is all forgiving
all compassionate fight them till there
is no persecution and the religion is
allahs then if they give over there
shall be no enmity save for
evildoers the Quran also mandates the
killing of those who become Muslims but
then leave the faith the Quran says they
wish that you should disbelieve as they
disbelieve and then you would be equal
therefore take not to yourselves friends
of them until they immigrate in the way
of Allah that is until they join the
Muslims then if they turn their backs
take them and slay them wherever you
find them take not to yourselves any one
of them as friend or
helper the fighting that the Quran
commands must continue until the entire
world is under the rule of Islam the
Quran says fight them till there is no
persecution and the religion is allahs
entirely then if they give over surely
Allah sees the things they
do the Quran even tells Muslims to
strike Terror into the hearts of the
enemies of Allah make ready for them it
says whatever force and strings of
horses you can to strike Terror into the
hearts of the enemy of Allah and your
enemy and others besides them that you
don't know Allah knows them and whatever
you expend in the way of Allah shall be
repaid you in full you will not be
wronged three times in the Quran Allah
tells Believers to kill them wherever
you find them the most famous of these
is the verse of the sword for which
Osama Bin Laden praised Allah in one of
his communic it goes like this then when
the sacred months are drawn away slay
the idolators wherever you find them and
take them and confine them and lie and
wait for them at every place of Ambush
but if they repent and perform the
prayer and pay the arms then let them go
their way Allah is all forgiving all
compassionate repent pay the arms all
that means in other words if they
convert to Islam don't kill them the
Quran also commands Muslims to fight
against the people of the book that is
primarily Jews and Christians and
subjugate them under the rule of Islamic
law it says fight those who do not
believe in Allah in the last day and do
not forbid what Allah and his messenger
have forbidden such men has practice not
the religion of truth that is of course
Islam being of those who have been given
the book that is the people of the book
the Jews and the Christians until they
pay the gizia with willing submission
and feel feel themselves subdued the
Quran also provides a justification for
suicide bombing when it promises
Paradise to Those Who Kill and are
killed it says Allah has bought from the
Believers their lives and their
possessions and for them is the gift of
paradise they fight in the way of Allah
they kill and are
killed finally the Quran tells Muslims
to behead unbelievers and make a wide
Slaughter among them it says when you
meet the unbelievers strike their necks
then when you have made wide Slaughter
among them tie fast the bonds then set
them free either by Grace or Ransom till
the war lays down its loads so that's
three verses about slaying polytheists
and apostates and idolators wherever
they are found one about beating
disobedient women two about beheading
two mandating amputation is punishment
all this is in the Quran and more
however Muslim spokesman in the west
explain these away as applying only to
the 7th Century or under strict
circumstances Etc Etc the problem is
with so many Jihad Terror groups around
the world and with Sharia regimes being
so oppressive it's hard to see how all
this can be reconciled with the claim
that Islam is a religion of Peace for
more information about this see this
website
[Music]